KIND OF PROGRESS REPORT ON THE
MASTER PLAN FOR THE VETERANS
HOMES WHICH WAS THEN.
IN ITS INFANCY I SAID THEN. TO
THE THEN --
CALVET SECRETARY --
DOCTOR BOSS CHIANTI.
THAT HE HAD PROVIDED WELCOME
DIRECTION LEADERSHIP AT THE
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS AN ERROR
OF GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND
COOPERATION WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THAT'S AS TRUE.
TODAY AS IT WAS THEN.
IT'S ALSO A YEAR LATER HOWEVER
AND SO WE WOULD LIKE TO IT WOULD
BE GREAT TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCRETE IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAL
THAT HAS ACCOMPLISHED IN THE
LAST YEAR.
AS WELL AS SHARE WITH US WHAT
YOU CAN ABOUT RECENT PROGRESS ON
THE MASTER PLAN WHICH IS DUE IN
FEBRUARY. FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
NEW MEMBERS AND THEY ARE NOT
HERE YET BUT SAID I'D LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THE SECRETARY ABBAS
YANNI AS A PHYSICIAN SURGEON.
AND A VETERAN HIMSELF --
HE SERVED TWENTY SEVEN YEARS IN
THE US ARMY IN THE MARINE CORPS
IN THE MEDICAL CORPS.
AND HE RETIRED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AT THE RANK HAS BEEN
THE DEPARTMENT SECRETARY SINCE
HIS APPOINTMENT BY GOVERNOR
BROWN IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND WHY DON'T WE
CALL YOU UP RIGHT NOW AND WILL
START WITH AN OVERVIEW OF CALVET
AND I THINK WE ARE.
SCHEDULED TO FINISH AT FOUR
O'CLOCK A LOT OF MEMBERS HAVE
TRAINING SO --
WE'LL JUST KEEP.
R. I. ON THE CLOCK WELCOME
[inaudible]
GALGIANI.
NEW MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
KING THEM.
I THANK YOU ALL OF YOU THOSE
RETURNING AND NEW FOR ALL THAT
YOU DO TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
VETERANS.
I'VE COURSE --
LOVE BEING HERE TODAY WITH YOU
TODAY AND I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
ALL.
ABOUT THE EVOLUTION OF CAL THAT
THUS FAR.
AND TO JUST START OUR
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE DIRECTION
OF THE DEPARTMENT GOING FORWARD.
IT IS THE START OF A NEW CHAPTER
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A NEW YEAR
A NEW GOVERNOR A NEW BIENNIAL
LEGISLATIVE.
SESSION.
AND AS WE ALL LOOK FORWARD TO
THE FUTURE WITH WHAT I KNOW IS A
SHARED GOAL OF MAINTAINING
SERVICES OF THE HIGHEST ORDER.
TO OUR STATES VETERANS AND
SETTING THE PACE FOR THE NATION
IN DOING SO.
I CANNOT HELP BUT BE STRUCK FAR
WE HAVE COME.
AND HOW WHAT I SEE TODAY
CONTRAST WITH WHAT I FOUND WHEN
I WAS FIRST APPOINTED IN LATE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN MY INTENTION
TODAY IS TO UPDATE YOU ALL ON
THE CURRENT STATE OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND WHERE I'D LIKE TO
GO FROM HERE.
BUT IN ORDER TO DO THAT I HAVE
TO START BY EXPLAINING WHERE WE
WERE JUST SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
HOW WE ARRIVE WHERE WE ARE TODAY
[inaudible]
PARDON ME.
WHEN I BEGAN MY TENURE CALVET
WAS IN NEED OF TRANSFORMATION?
THE AGENCY HAD BEEN WEAKENED BY
LEADERSHIP TURN OVER AND WAS
SEARCHING FOR A CLEAR IDENTITY
AND CULTURE.
AT THE SAME TIME MANY OF OUR
PROGRAMS WERE EXPERIENCING GREAT%
EXPANSION IN THEIR SCOPE WE WERE
ABOUT TO OPEN A NEW CEMETERY IN
MONTEREY.
OPEN THE LAST OF FIVE NEW
VETERANS HOMES AND WE WERE ABOUT
TO START THE VETERANS HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
PROGRAM WHICH I WILL REFER TO
GOING FORWARD AS V. H. H. P..
AT THAT SAME TIME WE ARE ALSO
FACED WITH MANY CHALLENGES.
ESPECIALLY IN THE EIGHT VETERANS
HOMES.
MEETING THOSE CHALLENGES.
ESPECIALLY WITH YOUR HELP AND
INSTRUCTION REQUIRED THOUGHTFUL
AND STRICT PRIORITIZATION. FOR
US SAID CAL THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT PRIORITY AT THE TIME
WAS TO OPEN AND STAFF.
THE NEW VETERANS HOMES IN FRESNO
READING AND WEST LOS ANGELES.
AND AS WE DID THAT I SAW THAT
WHILE MOST OF THE HOMES PROVIDED
SAFE QUALITY CARE.
THEY WERE NOT THE EXCELLENT
MODELS OF CLINICAL CARE THAT I
EXPECTED AND THAT THEY ARE TODAY.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE
EIGHT HOMES SCATTERED ALL OVER
THE STATE WERE STANDALONE
ENTITIES.
THEY LACK THE COHESION AND
DEFICIENCIES OF A MODERN HEALTH
CARE NETWORK.
MANY OF THE HOMES WERE
STRUGGLING WITH LOWER STAR
RATINGS FROM THE US CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID SERVICES.
AND THEY WERE OPERATING WITH
DISPARATE PROCESS SEES OUTDATED
TECHNOLOGY. FOR THESE REASONS MY
EXECUTIVE TEAM AND I ESTABLISH
PRIORITIES FOR THE HOMES.
IN THE AREAS OF QUALITY OF CARE
AND STANDARDIZATION OF
OPERATIONS AMONG MANY OTHERS.
AND AS A RESULT OUR PERFORMANCE
IN MANY AREAS HAS GONE FROM
MERELY ADEQUATE TO OUTSTANDING
AND THE PROOF IS IN OUR OUTCOMES
SO LET ME NAME A FEW.
TODAY.
ALL FIVE OF OUR CMS RATED
VETERANS HOMES ARE RATED AT FOUR
OR FIVE STARS.
PUTTING THEM AMONG THE TOP
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
NATIONWIDE.
A DRAMATIC CHANGE FROM THREE
YEARS AGO WHEN ALL HOMES WERE AT
ONLY TWO STARS.
AND ALL FIVE ARE NOW ALSO RANKED
AMONG THE TOP ONE HUNDRED BEST
NURSING HOMES IN CALIFORNIA.
BY US NEWS AND WORLD REPORT THIS
LAST NOVEMBER.
ALL EIGHT OF OUR HOMES
CONSISTENTLY EXCEL IN THE ANNUAL
LICENSING SURVEYS WITH HIGH
MARKS AND OFTEN FLAWLESS RESULTS.
I HAVE TO ADMIT THESE ACCOLADES
ARE TO THE CREDIT OF OUR TEAM OF
HOME ADMINISTRATORS WHO BRING TO
THEIR JOBS AN AVERAGE OF TWENTY
FIVE YEARS EACH.
OF HEALTH CARE.
EXPERIENCE.
ADDITIONALLY WE'VE ADOPTED
TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTIONS TO
INCREASE PATIENT SAFETY
EFFICIENCY AND TO PROVIDE BETTER
SERVICES OVERALL WE HAVE GROWN
OUR TELEMEDICINE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE FEDERAL VA WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY LAUNCHING.
AN AUTOMATED PHARMACEUTICAL
PROBLEM PROGRAM IN ALL HOMES
WITH SKILL PROGRAMS SKILLED
NURSING --
LEVELS OF CARE.
AS OF LAST DECEMBER FOR THE
FIRST TIME VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES CAN NOW SUBMIT
APPLICATIONS. TO OUR HOMES.
THROUGH AN ONLINE PORTAL AND USE
THAT PORTAL TO CHECK THEIR PLACE
ON OUR ADMISSIONS WAITING LISTS.
WE HAVE OPENED HUNDREDS OF
ADDITIONAL SKILLED NURSING BEDS.
ARE WEST LOS ANGELES HOME NOW IS
AUTHORIZED TO HOUSE NEARLY FOUR
HUNDRED RESIDENTS AND IS ON
TRACK SOON TO BE COMPLETELY FULL.
WITH RESPECT TO OUR PROPOSED NEW
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY ON THE
YOUNG FILL CAMPUS.
WE HAVE BEGUN DETERMINING THE
SITE DETAILS AND THE PATH
FORWARD FOLLOWING LAST YEAR'S
RELATED BUDGET BUDGET ALLOCATION.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY FOR THE
HOMES.
I AM PLEASED TO TELL YOU THAT WE
HAVE JUST THIS MONTH.
ENTERED THE FINAL PHASE OF THE
STATE'S IT PROCUREMENT PROCESS
TO LAUNCH A NEW ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORD SYSTEM FOR ALL OF
OUR VETERANS HOMES.
LATER THIS YEAR.
BUT MORE REMAINS TO BE DONE.
IN OUR STANDARDIZATION OF CARE
IN THE HOMES ONE AREA OF
IMPROVEMENT I AM CURRENTLY
ADDRESSING.
IS HOW WE ENGAGE IN LEASES
LICENSES AND OTHER PARTNERSHIPS
IN OUR VETERANS HOME PROPERTIES
INCLUDING THE MUCH DISCUSSED YON
PHIL HOME.
I HAVE RECENTLY TAKEN A CRITICAL
STEP TO ENSURE THAT OUR LEASE
ARRANGEMENTS ARE MADE IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THE STATE.
OF OUR VETERAN HOME SYSTEM AND
MORE THE VETERANS WHO LIVE IN
THOSE HOMES.
I HAVE ISSUED A DIRECTIVE TO
COMPLETELY OVERHAUL OUR LEASE
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES AND OUR
PROPERTY REQUIREMENTS THAT ALL
AGREEMENTS.
MUST SUPPORT BOTH THE INTERESTS
OF THE STATE AND OF OUR RESIDENT
VETERANS.
A COPY OF THIS POLICIES BEEN
PROVIDED TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
AND AS WE IMPLEMENT --
THIS IMPROVED POLICY YOU WILL
CAN WE WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU.
REGARDING HOW BEST TO UTILIZE
THE ON FILL CAMPUS TO ITS
MAXIMUM POTENTIAL.
BECAUSE OF THE WORK WITH
CURRENTLY DOING AND THE
MILESTONES WE'VE ACHIEVED THE
CURRENT STATE OF VETERANS HOMES
I CAN REPORT.
IS NOW DISTINGUISHED BY
[inaudible]
COMPASSIONATE CARE.
HI PERFORMANCE STANDARDS AND
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION.
SO NOW YOU MAY BE WONDERING WHAT
WILL OUR HOMES LOOK LIKE IN THE
FUTURE.
YOU CAN REST ASSURED THAT THIS
QUESTION IS AT THE FOREFRONT OF
MY THINKING AND SOMETHING I AM
COMMITTED TO DEFINING.
CALIFORNIA'S VETERAN POPULATION
IS CHANGING.
AS OUR VETERANS CONTINUE TO AGE
INTO LONG TERM CARE.
WE MUST BE COGNIZANT THAT THEIR
MEDICAL NEEDS ARE GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT FROM THOSE OF OUR
CURRENT RESIDENTS.
WHO SERVED IN WORLD WAR TWO THE
KOREAN WAR AND EVEN THE VETERAN
THE VIETNAM WAR?
OUR TEAM HAS UNDERTAKEN AN
INDEPTH NEEDS ASSESSMENT THAT
WILL DRIVE PLANNING FOR OUR
HOMES FOR DECADES TO COME.
THIS ASSESSMENT.
THE FINDINGS WE DERIVE FROM IT.
AND THE FIRST PHASE OF FUTURE
PLANNING WILL BE COMPLETE BY THE
END OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR AT
WHICH TIME BY YOUR REQUEST.
WE WILL PROVIDE OUR FINAL REPORT
TO YOU.
I LOOK FORWARD TO USING THIS
VALUABLE TOOL TO TAKE OUR HOMES
INTO THE NEXT CHAPTER.
OF HOW CALIFORNIA MEETS VETERANS
NEEDS.
THIS NEEDS ASSESSMENT WILL ALSO
INFORM THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
MASTER PLAN FOR EACH OF OUR
HOMES THE VETERANS HOMES OF
CALIFORNIA FULFILL THE IMPORTANT
PROMISE MADE BY THE STATE TO
CARE FOR OUR AGED AND DISABLED
VETERANS.
AND IT IS MY SOLEMN COMMITMENT
TO ENSURE THAT WE NOT ONLY
FULFILL THIS PROMISE BUT THAT WE
DO SO WITH EXCELLENCE.
HOWEVER.
IF I COULD GO BACK IN TIME TO
DESIGN A PLAN FOR LOCATING THE
VETERANS HOMES.
THE MAP WOULD LOOK QUITE
DIFFERENT THAN IT.
IN THE BEST OF ALL POSSIBLE
WORLDS I WOULD HAVE YOU SPECIFIC
CRITERIA TO EVALUATE AND
PRIORITIZE WHERE TO BUILD THOSE
HOMES.
AND WHAT LEVELS OF CARE TO
PROVIDE IN THEM.
AND THE CRITERIA WOULD ALL BE
BASED ON PROXIMITY.
SIMILARLY TO A VA HOSPITAL
MEDICAL FACILITY PROXIMITY TO A
HIGH POPULATION OF VETERANS.
AND PROXIMITY TO ALL ROBUST
TRANSPORTATION AND SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
OTHER CRITERIA WOULD HAVE
INCLUDED BUILDING IN AREAS WITH
A REASONABLE COST OF LIVING FOR
EMPLOYEES.
AND A LARGE EMPLOYEE REGISTRY OF
AVAILABLE BACK FILL WORKERS.
SO SINCE WE HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
HINDSIGHT WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
NOT THE BEST OF ALL POSSIBLE
WORLDS BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAVE HOMES THAT DIVERGED GREATLY
FROM ALL OF THOSE CRITERIA.
BUT WE DO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IN
PART DUE TO A LEGISLATIVE
MANDATE TO CONDUCT A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT.
AND A MASTER PLAN THAT WILL
FOSTER POLICY DISCUSSION AND
DECISIONS AND MY HOPE IS THAT AS
WE FORMULATE A PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE YOU WILL ALL BE PARTNERS
WITH ME.
IN HELPING US TO ACCOMPLISH
THESE CHANGES SO THAT FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE PUT THE NEEDS OF OUR
CURRENT RESIDENCE AS WELL AS
THOSE OF FUTURE.
GENERATIONS OF VETERANS ABOVE
ALL ELSE.
SO I SPOKE AT LENGTH ABOUT OUR
VETERANS HOMES IN PART BECAUSE
THEY MAKE UP NEARLY 80% OF MY
BUDGET AND 90% OF MY WORK FORCE.
AND BECAUSE I NEEDED TO
PRIORITIZE THEIR IMPROVEMENT
WHEN I CAME TO CAL THAT.
BUT I'D ALSO LIKE TO ENSURE TO
SHARE WITH YOU THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND FUTURE PLANS.
FOR THE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
SERVE VETERANS.
LET'S START AS A RESULT OF THE
VOTER APPROVED PROPOSITION ONE
BOND MEASURE AND NO.
YES MA'AM.
OF TO INTERRUPT RIGHT NOW BUT I
THOUGHT MAYBE BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
A LIST OF PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH DO YOU MIND
IF.
ANYBODY HAS QUESTIONS BECAUSE
YOU'RE DONE WITH THE HOMES RIGHT
NOW RIGHT EFFECTIVELY OKAY RIGHT.
AND I THINK THAT MAYBE INSTEAD
OF WAITING ALL THE WAY TILL THE
END DOES ANYBODY HAVE.
QUESTIONS ON THE HOME
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL
MR DIRECTOR [inaudible]
GREAT JOB.
QUESTION ON YON PHIL.
BUILT IN --
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOUR HOW MANY
ACRES IS IT ON I DON'T HOLD ME
TO THE EXACT NUMBER BUT IN
EXCESS OF SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
JUST NORTH OF NAPA VALLEY
CORRECT.
IT IT'S IN THE HEART OF NAPA
COUNTY IN THAT WINE PRODUCING
AREA.
HOME IS SURROUNDED BY VINEYARDS
WHOSE NAMES YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
HOW FAR AWAY IS YON PHIL FROM
THE NEAREST VA --
HOSPITAL.
A LONG DRIVE.
VETERANS A RESIDENTS OF OUR HOME
NOT JUST IN NOW FILLED BUT YOU
KNOW WE'RE READING IS SHASTA
COUNTY.
THE VETERANS AND THEIR ALSO WHEN
THEY NEED A CUTE MEDICAL CARE
PROVIDED ONLY BY THE FEDERAL Vl
<c.green>.</c>
THEY MUST BOARD TRANSPORTATION.
TO GO EITHER TO PALO ALTO FOR
MILEY IN THE HEART OF SAN
FRANCISCO MARTINEZ OR HEARING
MADE HER SACRAMENTO.
WHAT WOULD BE THE AVERAGE TIME
FOR THOSE --
I THINK THE QUICKEST TURNAROUND
IS PROBABLY FOUR HOURS AND
THAT'S JUST FOR A SIMPLE BLOOD
CHECKED HER BLOOD PRESSURE.
NOW CHAT SO IF A VETERAN HAS A
HEART ATTACK WHERE DO THEY GO --
TO WE'RE CONTRACTED --
WITH LOCAL HOT ALI I THINK IS
THE PRIMARY HOSPITAL IN NAPA
VALLEY [inaudible]
SO.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO REPLACE
YON PHIL CORRECT WE'VE ALREADY
IF I MAY BRAG A LITTLE BIT WE'VE
REACHED THE 90% MARK OF SUCESS
WITH THE FEDERAL VA.
WE'VE BEEN APPROVED TO PUT IN A
THREE TO FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR.
REPLACEMENT FACILITY --
TENTATIVELY SCHEDULED FOR YON
PHIL BUT WE COULD DISCUSS --
TO REPLACE.
THREE BUILDINGS PRESENTLY USED
HALDEMAN EISENHOWER AND
ROOSEVELT PRESENTLY HOUSING ARE
INTERMEDIATE CARE ARE SKILLED
NURSING CARE AND OUR MEMORY CARE.
POPULATION.
THESE ARE IN BUILDINGS THE
LATTER TWO RECENTLY RENOVATED
ABOUT TWELVE YEARS AGO BUT THESE
WERE BUILDINGS THAT WERE BUILT
AROUND THE TIME --
OFFER A HARBOR [inaudible]
VERY WELL.
THE ATTACK ON PEARL HARBOR.
SO THROUGH THE CHAIR MAY I ASK A
DIRECT QUESTION.
FINALLY THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO.
I'M NOT ASKING FOR A
RECOMMENDATION BUT COULD YOU PUT
INTO YOUR MIX OF RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON WHAT IF
YON PHIL WAS DOWN SCALED.
DOWN WE USE THAT. SIX HUNDRED
PLUS ACRES OF INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE REAL ESTATE.
HALL [inaudible] FOR FINANCING.
OTHER FACILITIES IN.
OTHER GEOGRAPHIC POSITIONS
CLOSER TO THE VA AND ALL THE
CRITERIA YOU SAID THAT IF.
IT WAS A PERFECT WORLD YOU COULD
SATISFY RIGHT [inaudible]
CHAU.
YOU HAVE --
TO YES YES YES AND YES OKAY OKAY
TO START WITH THAT BUT THE WORLD
I WORK IN FIRST ON DEALING WITH.
THE LARGEST.
VETERANS HOME IN THE NATION THE
MOST POPULOUS NURSING HOME OF
ANY KIND MILITARY OR CIVILIAN IN
THE NATION BY A FACTOR OF THREE
AND THE OLDEST VETERANS CEMETERY
THERE ARE PEOPLE INTERRED AT YON
PHIL WHO FOUGHT IN THE CIVIL WAR
AND EVEN AT THE ALAMO.
A THESE OF THE MEXICAN AMERICAN
WAR.
IT'S HELLO GRAND AND GROUND ITS
THE OLDEST NURSING HOME IN THE
COUNTRY EXCEPT FOR MAYBE A A
SMALL HOME IN MAINE.
IN ORDER NO MAIN THAT CLAIMS --
PRIMACY OF PLACE.
BUT IT'S IT'S BECOME OVER THE
DECADES CENTURY.
IF YOU WILL A VERY INTIMATE PART
OF THE CULTURE OF NAPA COUNTY --
AND WE'RE GONNA WIND UP TALKING
ABOUT ISSUES I THINK AFTER NEXT
WEEK WHEN THE STATE WATER OF A
COMES OUT WITH A REPORT ON CAL
THAT'S HANDLING IN THE PAST OF
LEASES.
LEASING OUT OVER THE DECADES OF
ASPECTS OF THAT PROPERTY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE COMMUNITY SOME
MAY SAY TO THE EXCLUSIVE BENEFIT
OF THE COMMUNITY --
AND NOT TO THE THESE LEASES DO
NOT READ DOWN TO NECESSARILY TO
THE BENEFIT OF THE RESIDENTS
THAT LIVE THERE --
HERE RIGHT.
IT -- COULD
WE TALK ABOUT.
SKILL I I THINK THAT WHEN THIS
WATER COMES OUT THAT WILL BE THE
FIRST QUESTION IN PEOPLE'S MINDS
IS HOW BETTER TO USE THAT CAMPUS.
DO I THINK THAT.
I SEE POLITICALLY AND I THINK
THAT POLITICALLY WE CAN.
CONSIDER ABANDONING THAT
PROPERTY ALL TOGETHER.
I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY TO USE A
WORLD WAR TWO EXPRESSION A
BRIDGE TOO FAR FOR ME.
BUT IN MANY WAYS IT WOULD MAKE
LOGICAL AND FINANCIAL AND
MEDICAL SENSE. TO PUT A NEW FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY.
ACROSS THE STREET FROM MAY THIRD --
A VETERANS HOSPITAL RIGHT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO.
IT MEETS ALL THE CRITERIA.
PROXIMITY TO A FEDERAL VA GREAT
INFRASTRUCTURE HIGH DENSITY OF
VETERAN POPULATION PEOPLE CAN
AFFORD TO LIVE HERE.
MY EMPLOYEES CANNOT AFFORD TO
LIVE ANYWHERE NEAR THE YOUNG
FILL CAMPUS OR THE WEST LA
CAMPUS
IT'S HARD TO RETAIN AND RECRUIT
EMPLOYEES --
SO YOU ASH THE THE SIXTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR QUESTION.
OF MISTER GLORIA HAD A QUESTION.
HELLO SIMPLISTIC THIS SECTOR I
COULD SEE YOU --
JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE HOMES THEMSELVES FOR STUFF.
AND HAD FORGIVE ME IF YOU COVER
THIS IN YOUR INITIAL COMMENTS
BEFORE I WAS ABLE TO GET HERE.
CURRENT SECURITY SITUATION AT
YON PHIL WHAT SORT OF HAPPENED
LAST YEAR --
TO INCREASE OR IMPROVE SECURITY
AT THAT LOCATION SURE --
KEEPING IN MIND THAT THIS IS AN
OPEN CAMPUS AND THIS IS A HOME A
HOME IT'S OUR OUR RESIDENT FED
AS WITH THAT PEOPLE ARE WARDS OF
THE STATE THESE ARE FREE
CITIZENS.
AND SO IT'S AN OPEN CAMPUS MAYBE
EVEN MORE OPEN IF I CAN BY
REFERRING TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOCALS A REFERENCES.
TO THE FACT THAT LOTS OF PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY COME ON TO USE
THE SWIMMING POOL THE BASEBALL
FIELD THE NAPA COUNTY MUSEUM THE
THEATER AND I'M JUST.
TOUCHING THE SURFACE.
SO BUT WE'RE VERY COGNIZANT OF
WHAT HAPPENED --
THANKS.
TO UP.
THE WHAT HAPPENED TO ONE OF OUR
LESS SEIZE ON THE PROPERTY --
SO THAT I SHOULD TELL YOU THAT
THE PATHWAYS UP HOME PROGRAM --
DISBANDED WITHIN A MONTH AND WE
CAME TO A MUTUAL AFTER THAT IN
THE MEANTIME WE HAVE ASKED THE
AND THE CA A CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL.
HAS NOW GRACES THE CAMPUSWITH A
PERMANENT PRESENCE OKAY WHERE
THEY DID NOT HAVE THAT BEFORE.
OKAY SO AND THEY THEY ARE FREE
TO USE THE DINING HALL AND IT
GRATIFY IS THE RESIDENTS TO KNOW
WHEN TO SEE UNIFORMS CH P.
PEOPLE --
HAVING A CUP OF TEA OR COFFEE
WITH THE SO.
I I CANNOT TURN THE YON PHIL
VETERANS THAT THE VETERANS HOME
CALIFORNIA DOWN FULL CANNOT
BECOME A FORTRESS.
I GET THAT AND IT'S THE BALANCE
OF HOW DO YOU.
NOT HAVE SOMETHING LIKE THAT
HAVE EVER HAPPEN AGAIN IN THIS
OF THE STUFF LEGISLATURE COULD
HELP WITH --
HOWEVER MAKING SURE PROBABLY
RESOURCE TO PROTECT THE THAT
INTO THE VERY IS IMPORTANT TO ME --
ON THE ON PAGE.
OF SORRY SON NUMBERED --
DOES THE CHART SHOWING IN
FACILITIES BEDS CAPACITY BUDGET
BEDS THERE'S A DELTA BETWEEN BAD
CAPACITY IN BUDGET BEDS OF FIVE
HUNDRED IS THERE A WHAT IF.
BEYOND US NOT GIVING ENOUGH
MONEY -- IS
THERE A REASON WHY THIS FIVE
HUNDRED BEDS ARE NOT OCCUPIED.
ELSEWHERE BUT I'M NOT SURE PAGE
AGAIN AND SAY THIS IS THE CHART --
THE BEDS IN THE CAPACITIES IT'S
ALL RIGHT --
AND THERE'S THE FIVE HUNDRED
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE ACTUAL
NUMBER OF CAPACITY BEDS VERSES
BUDGET BEDS OKAY BECAUSE I I
DIDN'T HAVE THIS INTO THE I'M
SORRY -- MY
DEPUTY SECRETARY KOBE --
COLBY PETERSON COULD PROBABLY
GIVE YOU A GOOD ANSWER FOR THIS.
A GOOD A GOOD AFTERNOON KOBE
PETERSON W. SECTOR VETERANS
HOMES -- SO --
WHAT?
WE WERE LOOKING AT THE CHART
THIS WHEN WE GOT HERE AS WELL I
THINK OF A NUMBER OF THESE.
THE THE STAFF NEEDS TO BE
UPDATED OKAY --
THERE IS JUST THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CAPACITY AND
BETWEEN --
BUDGETED BEDS --
ESSENTIALLY THERE'S A NUMBER OF
BEDS THROUGHOUT.
ALL EIGHT EIGHT VETERANS HOMES
THAT ARE NOT FILLED BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE WE DON'T STAFF --
TO FILL IN THERE WASN'T THE NEED
FOR THE FOR THE WAITING LIST FOR
THOSE AREAS WE GET A NUMBER BEDS
IN BARSTOW THAT HAVE NOT BEEN.
BILL THERE'S THERE'S A THERE'S A
BIT THERE'S SEVENTY FIVE BEDS
AND AND YON PHIL.
IN IN ONE OF OUR BUILDINGS THAT
HAS NOT BEEN FILLED BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO DEMAND TO FILL IT.
SO THERE'S A THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THAT WE TRY
TO MAXIMIZE THE BUDGET BASED
UPON THE NEED --
AS MUCH AS WE CAN --
WHAT WE WILL DO A LOOK AT THAT
CHART AND WE'LL UPDATE IT --
AND HAVE THAT TO YOU FOR THIS
WEEK AND I'M WHAT I'M GETTING AT
IS A CURIOSITY OF HOW MUCH IT IS
ME AS A LEGISLATOR NOT
APPROPRIATE IN THE FUNDS TO MAKE
THOSE FULLY UTILIZED.
ALWAYS A BLENDOF LACK OF MARKET
DEMAND COUPLE WITH MAYBE SOME
RENOVATIONS WITH BEDS ARE
ACTUALLY AVAILABLE AT THE MOMENT --
HILL WAS UNDERSTANDING WHAT THAT
FIVE HUNDRED IS AS YOU IMAGINE
COMING FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT'S
ANYWAY COUNTY WHERE TO MY
UNDERSTANDING WE HAVE A WAITING
LIST TO GET IN.
A TO THE CHáVEZ TO HOME.
ANY ANY INDICATION OF NOT FULL
UTILIZATION JUST STRUCK ME AS
ODD BUT YOU'VE ALREADY EDUCATED
ME THAT FOSTERS MAY BE DIFFERENT
ANGELES.
TO AT THIS SITE ACT IS A PARTIAL
ANSWER LET ME ADD AND AND
ESPECIALLY IN PREPARATION FOR
ARE AND WEEK WE ALREADY HAVING
CLEANS OF WHAT THIS NEEDS
ASSESSMENT IS GOING TO DO.
PARTICULAR IN YOUR AREA AND
YOURS MADAM CHAIR AND AND THE
VENTURA HOME --
THE PRESSURE BUILDING FOR HIGHER
LEVEL OF CARE THAN WE PRESENTLY
PROVIDE THERE IN YOUR AREA
PARTICULARLY FROM MEMORY CARE.
SO -- IT'S
NOT SO MUCH AN EMPTY BED IT'S
WHO'S IN THAT BAD SURE AND WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT THAT MIX --
WE DO HAVE SOME SOLUTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE FROM SKILLED NURSING TO
MEMORY KERR CHULA VISTA IT WOULD
INVOLVE --
PREVENTING ELOPEMENT BY BUILDING
BUILDING A SIMPLE --
GARDEN WALL.
BUT WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT WELL
IN THE MATCH I KNOW I'VE GONE
TAKING TOO MUCH TIME BUT I
APPRECIATE --
KNOWING MORE ABOUT THAT AGAIN
HOW MUCH OF ITS APPROPRIATIONS
QUESTION IF WE'RE PROPERLY
RESOURCING YOU.
CARE FOR FOLKS --
IT IS A TOP CONCERN IN SAN DIEGO --
AND WILL LOOK FOR THAT TO THE
AUDIT COMING BACK AS WELL AS
WHATEVER RECOMMENDATIONS YOU
HAVE WHEN YOU WERE LIKE HEY WE
THINKING A MOMENT AGO.
BASED ON ALL THOSE VERY FACTORS
WHERE YOU THINK THINGS SHOULD BE --
YOU KNOW I'VE CARE PARDON ME FOR
BEING PART OF THE SAN DIEGO BUT
IF IF YOU IDENTIFY TO YOUR
WISDOM AND YOUR STAFFS --
INPUT THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
HOMES AND COMMUNITIES X. Y. Z.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW THAT JUST
BEFORE BASIS [inaudible]
THE MANAGER.
CERTAINLY OPEN ANOTHER.
HI AT THINGS FOR BEING HERE.
JUST CIRCLING BACK QUICKLY TO
THE YOUNG FELL CONVERSATION SO
YOU MENTIONED THE POSSIBILITY OF
RELOCATING SOME OF THAT CAPACITY
TO YOU PERHAPS HAVE ANOTHER
LOCATION IS THAT SOMETHING
YOU'RE EXPLORING.
FORMALLY OR BUT I KNOW I THINK
AT WHAT I SAID HERE TODAY IS
ABOUT AS FAR AS I'VE GONE OKAY
FAR OKAY TO BE HONEST.
RIGHT -- THE
THE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT VIA
FROM THE INTENDED PLANT THAT
BUILDING RIGHT THERE ON
AVAILABLE CAMPUS.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK
IS WORTH EXPLORING FORMALLY.
WELL -- AS
MR VOCAL --
POINTED OUT --
IT'S SO DIFFICULT FOR US WHEN
PEOPLE NEED --
ALMOST ANYTHING THAT THE FEDS
PROVIDE TO GET THEM THERE.
THEY'RE JUST NOT.
A SUMMER HOMES ARE NOT IN THE
BEST LOCATION. FOR THAT CARE.
SO I THINK WELL WE CAN LOOK WHEN
THE WATER COMES OUT AND AS WE
PROGRESS OF COURSE.
IF IF WE WERE TO TAKE THAT
SERIOUSLY I'D PROBABLY LOSE A
YEAR AND AND HAVING TO REDO SOME
ASSESSMENTS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
RIGHT WHY DON'T WE MOVE FORWARD
THEN WITH THE FARMING HOME LOAN
PROGRAM.
THANKS THANK YOU.
SO THE OTHER PROGRAMS AS
SURVEILLANCE I STARTED TO
MENTION THAT THE NOVEMBER BALLOT
AND THE VOTERS --
AGAIN --
APPROVED A ONE BILLION DOLLAR
BOND AUTHORITY HAVE ALL ALLOW
OUR FARM AND HOME LOAN PROGRAM.
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE HOME
LOANS TO VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES FOR A FEW MORE YEARS.
YOU SHOULD KNOW ESPECIALLY THE
NEW MEMBERS.
SINCE.
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE AFTER TWENTY
SEVEN SUCCESSFUL CONSECUTIVE
TRIPS TO THE BALLOT.
THE PROGRAM HAS PROVIDED HOME
LOANS FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
VETERANS.
IT'S ALMOST A HALF MILLION
VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA GOT THEIR
HOME LOANS FROM OUR PROGRAM.
AND THE VOTERS HAVE APPROVED IT
TWENTY SEVEN TIMES IN A ROW
WITHOUT FAIL.
IN OCTOBER.
TWENTY SIXTEEN CALVET OPEN TO
THE CENTRAL COAST VETERANS
CEMETERY IN MONTEREY.
THE CEMETERY CURRENTLY HAS A
PAST CITY CAPACITY FOR FIVE
THOUSAND COLUMN BERIA AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE PLANNING PHASE
OF A PLATE PLANNING PORTION OF
PHASE.
TWO OF THE CEMETERY WHICH WILL
DEVELOP THE PROPERTY FURTHER TO
ACCEPT TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE IN GROUND BURIALS.
WE CONTINUE TO BUILD UP OUR TWO
SEPARATE DIVISIONS FOR WOMEN AND
MINORITY VETERANS.
THIS YEAR EACH DIVISION WILL
EXPAND ON THE IMPORTANT WORK
THEY DO. TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
IMMIGRATION SERVICES. TO EXPAND
OUR REACH TO TRIBAL LANDS TO
CREATE NEW OBJECTIVES FOR D. V.
BE EASE THE DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAM.
AND TO INCREASE SUPPORT FOR
WOMEN VETERANS WHO FILE FOR
BENEFITS AND COMPENSATION.
OUR CALIFORNIA STATE STATE
APPROVING AGENCY [inaudible]
SEE SAVE. FOR VETERANS EDUCATION
CONTINUES TO ACT AS A NATIONAL
MODEL IN THE APPROVAL AND
OVERSIGHT OF THE NEARLY ELEVEN
HUNDRED SCHOOLS WHICH SEEK TO
OFFER GI BILL AND EDUCATIONAL
BENEFITS. TO TO VETERANS AND
THEIR DEPENDENTS.
WE HAVE CALVET TAKE OUR ROLE OF
OVERSIGHT VERY SERIOUSLY AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ASSIDUOUSLY TO ENSURE THAT
VETERANS RECEIVE THE VEST BEST
POSSIBLE EDUCATION. FOR THE
BENEFIT THEY GET.
CALIFORNIA HAS IMPLEMENTED TO
FIRST IN THE NATION PROGRAMS FOR
VETERANS IN THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS.
THE FIRST OF THESE IS VH PRETTY
VETERANS HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION PROGRAM.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY COLLEGE A FAKE.
CAL THAT'S B. H. H. P. PROGRAM
HAS TO DATE AWARDED OVER THREE
HUNDRED ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
TO DEVELOP MULTI FAMILY
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING FOR
VETERANS.
THIS TRANSLATES INTO MORE THAN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
HOUSING UNITS.
AS A FUNDING SOURCE THE V. H. H.
P. PROGRAM ALSO BRINGS IN NINE
DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL OUTSIDE
FUNDING FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR OF
H. H. P. P. FUND.
THE H. H. P. FUNDING THAT WE
PROVIDE.
AS OF TODAY THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR VETERAN HOUSEHOLDS
ARE HOUSED OR ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF BEING HOUSED.
AND MANY MORE WILL BE HOUSED BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR.
WE STILL HAVE SEVERAL MORE
ROUNDS OF FUNDING TO AWARD WITH
THE REMAINING MONIES AVAILABLE
TO ME.
THIS PROGRAM IS BUILDING
THOUSANDS OF UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR VETERANS AND ACTING
AS A FUNDING MULTIPLIER FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR NON VETERANS.
MY DEPARTMENT WILL CONTINUE
PRIORITIZING HOUSING FOR
VETERANS AND IS LOOKING FORWARD
TO FINDING INNOVATIVE WAYS TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS IN
OUR STATE.
THE OTHER FIRST IN THE NATION
PROGRAM DEVELOPED IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS.
IS THE CALIFORNIA TRANSITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR CAL TAP.
THIS PROVIDES CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC INFORMATION TO
SEPARATING SERVICE MEMBERS.
THE GOALS OF THE PROGRAM ARE. TO
INFORM AND CONNECT VETERANS OF
ALL THE EARNED FEDERAL AND STATE
BENEFITS. TO COORDINATE WITH
COMMUNITY PROVIDERS IN THE
DELIVERY OF SERVICES.
AND TO SUPPORT VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES SAYS THEIR NEEDS
CHANGE OVER TIME.
WE LAUNCHED CAL TAP IN THE
SUMMER OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THE GROWTH IN DEMAND OF THE
PROGRAM IS STAGGERING.
SINCE THEN CAL TAP HAS BEEN
INCORPORATED INTO THE TRANSITION
PROGRAMS OF EVERY MAJOR MILITARY
INSTALLATION IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S MORE THAN. TWENTY TWO TO
DATE CAL TAP HAS TOUCHED OVER
FOUR THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FORTY VETERANS AND ACTRESS
ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS.
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET.
THE PROGRAM WILL ADD EIGHT
ADDITIONAL STAFF SO THAT WE CAN
EXPAND INTO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ACROSS THE STATE.
CAL TOPPLE ALSO DEPLOY AN
EXPANDED ONLINE KID CURRICULUM
LATER THIS YEAR.
THAT WILL ALLOW VETERANS OF ANY
YEAR OF SERVICE TO ACCESS
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR BENEFITS.
THIS PROGRAM IS THE FOUNDATION
OF ALL FOR FUTURE OUTREACH
PROGRAMS FOR CAL THAT.
I JUST HAVE A FEW CONCLUDING
REMARKS BUT MAYBE.
WATER PAUSE HERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE OTHER PROGRAMS.
OF WE HAVE A QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARC BERMAN WERE
ROUGH THANK YOU --
YES SO YOU SAID YOU'RE AT OF THE
CAL TOP PROGRAM IS AT TWENTY TWO
FACILITIES I ASSUME THAT
INCLUDES CAPITAL.
TEN PICK INCLUDE A WILSON WAS
THE PILOT AND WHEN THE OTHER
ARMY NAVY AIR FORCE MARINES AND
COAST GUARD INSTALLATIONS HEARD
ABOUT WHAT WAS HAPPENING THERE.
THEY CLIMBED OVER EACH OTHER TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE COULD DO THE
SAME THING ON THEIR BASIS THAT'S
EXCELLENT SO HOW MANY SERVICE
MEMBERS ARE SERVING PER YEAR OR
PER MONTH TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION HANDY [inaudible]
NO. TWENTY COME UP AND SAY IT
AGAIN PLEASE.
THE KING BED DEPUTY KEEP BOYLAN.
VETERAN SERVICES.
HI -- GOOD
AFTERNOON.
NATIONWIDE ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND MILITARY PERSONNEL EXIT
ON THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
APPROXIMATELY AND RETURNED TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU HAVE THE BREAKDOWN FOR
PENDLETON --
WE DON'T EXACTLY NOW --
AND YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT AVERAGES
ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE PARTICIPANTS.
EVERY SESSION WHICH IS ABOUT
ONCE A MONTH NAY USUALLY HAVE A
JUNE GENERAL ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
FOLKS THAT EXIT OUT OF THEIR PER
MONTH --
IDEALLY WHAT WE DO INITIALLY IS
TRY TO FIND THOSE FOLKS THAT
HAVE ALREADY IDENTIFIED THEY'RE
PLANNING ON STAYING IN
CALIFORNIA OR HAVE ANY KIND OF
HOPES DREAMS OR THOUGHTS OF
STANDING CALIFORNIAN THOSE THE
FOLKS WHO WANT TO TARGET MAKE
SURE THEY GET INTRODUCED TO
THEIR COMMUNITY NETWORK OF CARE.
THAT'S EXCELLENT AND ON THAT
POINT DECIDED TO TRANSITION BUT
THEY AREN'T SAYING CALIFORNIA
BUT HAVE THAT DREAM OF RETURNING
TO CALIFORNIA --
HOW DO YOU REACH THEM TO INFORM
THEM ABOUT THE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES WE OFFER HERE --
WE HAVE NO UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S
WHERE THE BIG CHALLENGES --
FEDERALLY IT'S NOT KNOW WHETHER
STATE HAS THIS PROGRAM ON THE
STATE LEVEL IN THE FEDERAL LEVEL
IT'S STILL.
A VERY SCATTER SHOT IN TERMS OF
IDENTIFYING VETERANS AS THEY
RETURN YOUR STATE WERE.
OR FORTUNATELY --
MUCH FURTHER ALONG THAN MANY
OTHER STATES BUT AND
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF THE STATE
STATES ARE DRAGGING FAR BEHIND
IT HAVEN'T REALLY.
JUST HAVING A REALLY DIFFICULT
TIME EVEN IDENTIFYING VETERANS
WHEN TEY RETURN TO THEIR STATE --
WE SIMILARLY OF HAD THAT
CHALLENGE WE WE GET INFORMATION
ON VETERANS RETURNING THROUGH A
DIGITAL DATABASE OF THEIR HOME
OF RECORD BUT REALLY --
THERE'S NO WARM HAND OFF ON ONE
LEAVES THE MILITARY FROM A POST
OUTSIDE THE STATE AND RETURNS.
SELL PART OF CAL TAP IS CREATING
THAT STAY COLLECT COMMITTEE
BASED SYSTEM OF CARE SO
REGARDLESS OF WHAT ENTRY POINT
THAT VETERAN COMES INTO.
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH US CITY
COUNTY OFF OF SOME SORT --
THAT WERE CONNECTED WITH THAT
ENTRY POINTS SO THEN WE CAN GET
THEM KIND OF INTO THAT.
INTO THAT SYSTEM AND HOPEFULLY --
PUT THEM ON THE RIGHT PATH TO
WHATEVER SERVICES THEY NEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Q. OF THE BY I HAD A A JUST
ANOTHER --
QUESTION ABOUT CAL TAP YOUR TALK
ABOUT MOVING INTO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHICH I THINK IS A VERY
GOOD WAY TO REACH OUT BUT WE
ONLY HAVE EIGHT NEW STAFF
MEMBERS SO HOW ARE YOU --
AT HOW DOES THAT LOOK YEAH LEE
RITUAL STAFFING FOR THE PROGRAM
WAS FIVE SO ARE TOO BIG PUSHES --
OBVIOUSLY THE CAL TAP IS VERY
MUCH ARM FROM IS IS EVEN PER
YEAR PER UNIT --
ENLISTMENT. TO FINALIZATION AND
BURIAL AND EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN
ANY ANY POINT TO THAT VETERAN
HAS A TRANSITION OUR LIFE BETTER
IN SPECIFIC OR NOT AS AN AGENCY
WE FEEL AS A LEAD ADVOCATE.
WE NEED TO HAVE THAT CONNECTION
SO WE TRY TO MAKE THAT
RELATIONSHIP AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE MINUTES TIME HOUSES.
WHATEVER TRANSITION THAT BETTER
AND MAYBE --
FOR PART OF THAT IS. TOO BIG OUT
THE GATE PRIORITIES WE MADE OUR
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALMOND CSU
SYSTEM.
WE FIRST STARTED WE HAD PENSION
GOING IN WE DID.
A FEW DOWN SOUTH IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
THEN WE HAD THE MILITARY
VETERANS MILITARY GOVERNOR'S
COUNCIL MEETING WHEN I PUT OUT
THE PLEA.
AND INFORM FOLKS ABOUT WE'RE
DOING A CAMP PENDLETON AND IT
WAS PEOPLE WERE EXCITED WELL
THAT ABSORB THOSE FIVE PEOPLE TO
PUT THOSE TWENTY THREE POSTS
ONLINE VERY RAPIDLY.
BECAUSE FORTUNATELY IT'S A IT'S
NOT EVEN ADJUSTED ADDITION TO
THE EXISTING PROGRAM WE HAVE A
WHOLE SEPARATE DAY WHERE IT'S
OUR AGENDA --
SO IT'S PRETTY INVOLVED.
THEN IT GAVE US THE NEEDED WE
FOUND QUICKLY THAT THE COMMITTEE
CALL SYSTEM WAS SOMETHING WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE BAND WITH FOR SO.
THOSE EIGHT FOLKS COUPLED WITH
FORTUNATELY A LOT OF A LOT OF
WORK FROM YOUR OFFICE.
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND OTHERS --
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF SUPPORT IN
THE VRC TO DEVELOP THE OUR
CITIES THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM IN FINALLY
FINALLY THERE'S BEEN SOME STABLE
FUNDING FOR THAT.
THAT THAT COUPLED WITH WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN THE GRANTS THAT
ARE BEING PUT OUT BY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR THE VRC
DEVELOPMENT.
IS WORKING RIGHT IN TANDEM WITH
OUR DEVELOPMENT OF THE CAL TECH
PROGRAM SO FORTUNATELY.
MOM SIMILAR TO THE MILITARY
POSTS ARE OUR STAFF IS
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR PUTTING THOSE TOGETHER --
FACILITATING THE PROGRAMS BRING
IN THE COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDER
GATHER HOLDERS TOGETHER.
IN SOME CASES WERE STATE
AGENCIES CALLIE CHAR FOR
INSTANCE WHEN IT FIRST STARTED
THEY FOUND THAT THEIR THEIR
STAFF MEMBER WAS OUT OF THE
OFFICE ALL THE TIME I GOT A CALL
AND SAID HI YOU KNOW.
JOE'S ALWAYS GONE NOW WE'RE LIKE
WELL WE LOVE JONES AND CYCLE WE
NEED IN THE OFFICE WE CAN
REALIZE THIS IS GOING TO BE SUCH.
AN ASK SO SOME OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S ON WE'VE HAD TO USE
THE STAFF MEMBERS TO FILL IN THE
SPOTS AND GIVE THEIR
PRESENTATION FOR THEM SO TO
SPEAK.
OM AND HELP THEM WITH SIGN UP
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AND
DO ALL THOSE SORTS OF THINGS
OTHER LIKE WORK FOR WHERE'S
THEIR THEIR EVERYTIME DCA IS
THERE EVERY TIME.
DEPENDS ON THE BAND WITH SO
THOSE EIGHT FIVE PEOPLE WILL BE
IT'LL BE VERY COORDINATED
BETWEEN.
TRYING TO STAND UP THE PROGRAM
ITSELF FACILITATE THOSE EVENTS
ARM FILL IN INTO THE
PRESENTATIONS WHERE STATE
AGENCIES OR EVEN COMMITTEE
PROVIDERS DON'T HAVE THE BAND
WITH TO MAKE ALL THE STOPS.
GENERALLY WE WE TRY TO BRING IN
THAT COMMUNITY SYSTEM OF CARE IN
EACH AREA LIKE WHATEVER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES NEXT TO THAT
MILITARY POST.
ARM OR OR SEE ISSUE OR WHATEVER
THOSE ARE THE FOLKS THAT COME IN
AS WE TRY TO USE ALL THOSE LOCAL
RESOURCES MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
AND THE DUTIES OF OUR STAFF ARE
MORE SO FOCUSED ON LIKE I SAID
CORD AGED CORD ADVANCE --
BRING IN ALL THE PARTNERS AND
THEN HELP FACILITATED ACTUALLY
TAKEN PLACE.
IF I COULD JUST QUANTIFY ONE
ASPECT OF THIS CASE ALREADY
MENTIONED THAT.
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS TAKE OFF THEIR
UNIFORMS SOMEWHERE IN THE WORLD
AND COME BACK TO CALIFORNIA EACH
YEAR. FOR THOSE AMONG THEM THAT
CHOOSE EDUCATION AS THEIR FIRST
NEXT ADVENTURE IN LIFE 90% OF
THEM STAR IN A CUTE THE TWO YEAR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE 90%.
THEY DON'T GO TO THE UC SYSTEM.
RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
SEC SO THAT'S WHERE YOU KNOW
EIGHT WHY HE ROBBED BANKS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE MONEY
IS THAT'S WHY WE'RE GOING AFTER
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND AND
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF FUNDING
OVER THE LAST.
COUPLE OF YEARS --
TO FUND THOSE AT CENTER SO ALL A
GREAT DIFFERENCE ARE COMING
TOGETHER VERY NICELY
[inaudible]
A CAN YOU I KNOW WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH YOU ON THE SEE SAVE
PROGRAM BUT CAN YOU TALK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE DIFFICULTIES --
THAT THEY'VE BEEN HAVING WITH --
ISSUING SUSPENSIONS TO FOR
PROFIT SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT
COMPLYING WITH THE LAW
[inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
I'M.
I'M GONNA LET KEITH HANDLE THIS
BECAUSE RIGHT MAY BE --
MY LANGUAGE MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME AND YOUR THAN HAS
[inaudible]
RESUMEN.
ON IT'S IT'S OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
YOU'RE WELL AWARE IT'S IT'S A
IT'S A HUGE CHALLENGE WITH THE
IN ND I WOULD SAY CALIFORNIA
HAS THE THE CHALLENGE OF
OVERSIGHT OF MORE THAN THIRTEEN
HUNDRED INSTITUTIONS AND SAY
POST SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS
THAT'S PUBLIC PRIVATE NONPROFIT
OR FOR PROFIT --
THAT IS SOMETHING WE TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY AND TAKE GREAT PRIDE
IN OUR EFFORTS THERE.
HOWEVER IT IS AN OVERWHELMING
CHALLENGE AT TIMES ON THE WAY
THE PROGRAM BREAKS DOWN IS THE
VA THERE'S A BENEFIT BASICALLY
THAT.
YOU GONNA MILITARY GET THE GI
BILL INCREDIBLY GENEROUS BENEFIT
INCREDIBLY GENEROUS BENEFITS --
HAVING THE MOST SCHOOLS AROUND.
THE MOST VETERANS AND THE
HIGHEST COST OF LIVING ARE ALL
FACTORS THAT MAKE THIS.
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGE TO
MANAGING CALIFORNIA LOT OF FOLKS
COME HERE FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS --
NOT ALL TO PROVIDE THE BEST
EDUCATION TO OUR VETERANS IN THE
STATE.
HAVING SAID THAT LIKE I SAID WE
OVERSEE ANY PRIVATE ANY POST
SECONDARY PRIVATE PUBLIC FOR
PROFIT NONPROFIT DEGREE --
THAT YOU COULD BE A NON GREED
NON AN NC NON COLLEGE DEGREE
PROGRAM A CERTIFICATE PROGRAM
TWO THOUSAND NINE THEY REDID THE
GI BILL TO ALLOW VOCATIONAL
TRAINING IN A VARIETY OF OTHER
THINGS.
IN THAT THAT REALLY --
MASON GIVE SOME ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES IN ANY GIVEN YEAR WE
DO ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND PROGRAMS
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT WE OVERSEE AND
IDENTIFY --
IN APPROVED.
IN.
EVALUATION SAY AND APPROVE.
WITH THAT --
WITH OUR CONTRACT WITH THE VA
THERE'S ALSO THE REQUIREMENT TO
ON TO WHAT'S CALLED COMPLIANCE
SURVEYS.
SO WHEN IT BREAKS DOWN FOLKS
GOING THE MILITARY TO GET THIS
WONDERFUL BENEFIT.
WHEN THEY GET OUT OF THE
MILITARY CONGRESS REALIZED OKAY
THESE FOLKS ARE GOING BACK TO
WHATEVER STATE?
WE UNDERSTAND THIS THE FEDERAL
BENEFIT THE MUST BE DISTRIBUTED.
HOWEVER EVERY STATE HAS THE
RIGHT.
TO SAY WHAT EDUCATION IS IN
THEIR STATE.
SUFFER THE SCA COMES AN ESSAY A
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH PAYMENT IS
Vl <c.green> EVERYTHING TO DO WITH</c>
APPROVALS.
IS AS A THAT DISTINCTION IS NOT
SO CLEAR ALL THE TIME.
A LOT OF THE THINGS WE DO THEY
MIGHT NOT AGREE WITH.
THEY PAY SCHOOLS THAT WE MIGHT
THINK THEY SHOULD BE BUT THEY
CONTROL THAT AND IN THEORY WE
CONTROL.
THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT.
A LOT OF THERE'S A LOT OF WHEN
THE RIGS ARE PUT IN PLACE
FEDERALLY.
THEY COULD HAVE THEY COULD BE A
LITTLE CLEARER --
THERE'S SOME AMBIGUITY IN
DIFFERENT PARTS THAT ARE OPEN
FOR INTERPRETATION TIME WE
CERTAINLY DON'T.
AGREE WITH THE VA ON THAT
INTERPRETATION.
WE'VE TAKEN STEPS WITHIN THE
STATE TO DEVELOP WHAT'S CALLED A
REASONABLE CRITERIA WITHIN THE
CONTRACT.
IT WITHIN LEGISLATE WITHIN THE
REGULATIONS AND SEE HOW FAR IT
ALLOWS THE STATE TO DEVELOP
WHAT'S CALLED --
REASONABLE CRITERIA --
SO SOME YEARS BACK AB TWENTY
NINETY NINE WE GOT PASSED WITH
YOUR SUPPORT VAN.
ON THAT ALLOWED THE RECOGNIZE
THAT AUTHORITY WITHIN THE STATE
ITSELF -- SO
WHAT THAT DOES IS THINGS THAT
THE VA MIGHT NOT THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR SCHOOL TO DO --
WE IN CALIFORNIA CAN DECIDE THAT
WE DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE --
A HURDLE THAT THAT SCHOOL MUST.
MUST CROSS IN ORDER TO BE
APPROVED HERE IN THE STATE --
THE GENERAL IS WHERE A LOT OF
THE CHALLENGES WITH THE VA.
HAPPEN IN THAT AREA --
ADDITIONALLY ON THE FRONT AND
THE ONE THING THAT THE STATE.
CONTROLS IF.
FORTY WITHOUT QUESTION.
IS IN THE APPLICATION PROCESS SO.
COUPLE YEARS BACK TO VA TRIED TO
STANDARDIZE THE WHICH WE FOUGHT
VERY HARD AGAINST.
ON THE STATE AT THIS POINT STILL
HAS THE RIGHT TO PUT IN THE
APPLICATION WHAT IT FEELS
NECESSARY.
AND WE REALIZE THAT'S THE ONE
PLACE WHERE WHEN PEOPLE FIRST
COME TO THE TABLE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TO ASK QUITE A
LOT OF THEM.
AND THAT INCLUDES TAX RETURNS
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
ACCREDITATION REPORTS ALL THESE
THINGS THAT IN THE PAST THEY HAD
NEVER ASKED FOR BEFORE.
ANTM.
SEC THAT THE POST SOME
CHALLENGES AND WE WE A THE
SCHOOL'S OBVIOUSLY SOME OF THOSE
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION.
MIGHT BE PRODUCT PROBLEMATIC
TOWARDS THEIR APPROVAL --
SO THOSE ARE GENERALLY THE BROAD
BROAD AREAS OF WHERE WE WE RUN
INTO.
RENTED THE CHALLENGES IN THE
PROCESS.
SO CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT --
BRIGHT WOULD DID THEY ATTEMPT --
TO SUSPEND.
BRIGHT WOODS SCHOOLS
[inaudible]
WE DID.
WE DID WE WE ACTUALLY HAD JUST
REINSTATED THEM.
PRIOR TO THEM GOING OUT OF
BUSINESS.
THAT WAS DUE --
TO DIRECTOR FROM THE VA --
THAT REQUIRED US --
TO SO WHEN A SCHOOL IS APPROVED
WHAT WHEN A SCHOOL COMES US A
SCHOOL HAS TO GO THROUGH CERTAIN
STEPS BEFORE THEY COME TO US.
IF THERE ARE CREDIT
INSTITUTIONAL MISSIVE TO BE
ACCREDITED IF THEY'RE
APPROPRIATELY THEY HAVE TO BE
REGISTERED SECRETARY STATE THEY
HAVE TO DO ALL THE DIFFERENT
BUSINESS THEY HAVE TO SCHOOL
MUST.
ON APPROVAL WES IS PREDICATED ON
APPROVAL BY THE BUREAU FOR POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
NOW WHEN WE GET THIS INFORMATION
OUR APPLICATION THEIR
ACCREDITATION REPORT.
THEY'RE BPP APPROVAL ARE AND AND
THE DETAILS OF THAT ANY THIS
INFORMATION FROM THEIR CREDIT.
ON THE FINANCIAL STATEMENTS --
THEY HAVE TO DISCLOSE WHETHER
THEY HAVE ANY PENDING LAWSUITS
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
THAT ARE GOING ON ALL
INFORMATION THAT WE FEEL IS
IMPORTANT IN MAKING THAT
DETERMINATION [inaudible]
OUR WE WOULD QUESTION SOME OF
THAT.
AND THE VA.
SAID WILL BASICALLY.
IF THEY'RE APPROVED BY ALL THESE
OTHER ENTITIES THEN WHY DO YOU
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THEM.
I SAID WELL BECAUSE WE'VE LOOKED
AT THE INFORMATION AND THOSE
ENTITIES HAVE THEM APPROVED --
BUT THEY SHOULDN'T BE.
IT'S SIMILAR TO CURRENT AND BACK
WHEN WHEN WE PULLED CORINTHIANS
APPROVAL A YEAR BEFORE THEY
CLOSE THEIR DOORS ON BECAUSE
WHAT WE SAW ON THE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS AND SOME OTHER ISSUES
THAT WERE HAVING.
THAT THEY WERE THEY WERE
HEMORRHAGING MONEY AND THAT
FOLKS WERE A HUGE RISK AND THAT
THE END WAS NEAR.
WE PULLED THEIR APPROVAL NOW BY
DOING SO WE SAVED VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA YEARS WORTH OF JR
THERE ARE IN GI BILL BENEFITS.
SAME SITUATION EFFECT
ACCREDITING BODY REPORTS AS THE
SCHOOL'S HORRIBLE.
BUT THIS DEAR CREDITOR ONCE
AGAIN YOU HAVE TO THINK THEIR
CREDITORS BEING PAID BY THE
SCHOOL.
IN THEIR PROVIDE NUMBER SERVICE
SUPPORT OF THAT SERVICES HEY WE
KNOW WE KNOW YOU'RE HORRIBLE.
WILL GIVE YOU A YEAR TO GET
BETTER.
WELL CONFEDERATE RELATIONS SAYS
THAT SCHOOL IS APPROVED FOR C.
SAFE AT ALL TIMES.
SO WITH A GREAT WE'RE GONNA PULL
YOUR APPROVAL AND WHEN YOU'RE
ALL BETTER IN YOUR CREDITING
BODY FEELS THAT YOU'RE ALL
BETTER.
YOU'RE MORE THAN WELCOME TO COME
BACK IS NO COST FOR APPLICATION
SO COME BACK IN.
CHOSE YOUR PAPERWORK AND SHOW
THAT ALL THOSE --
DEFICIENCIES OF IN MATT WOULD BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO APPROVE YOU
AGAIN --
THAT DOES NOT GO OVER VERY WELL --
BRIGHT WOOD WAS ONE OF THOSE
SITUATIONS ACTUALLY THERE WAS
ABOUT TWELVE SCHOOLS.
OVER THE SUMMER THERE WAS A
LAWSUIT INVOLVED THERE'S A LOT
OF ISSUES AROUND THAT BUT BRIGHT
WHAT IN PARTICULAR SO DIED
STALKS THE VA AND SAID WELL.
IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN YOU IN
IS VERY AT THE VERY LEAST NEED
TO PUT THAT IN WRITING.
SO THEY PUT OUT A OF A NATIONAL
DIRECTIVE OF SORTS --
STATING THE FOLLOWING WHICH IT'S
QUESTIONABLE I GUESS THERE'S
FOLKS THAT ARE CURRENTLY ARGUING
OUT WHETHER.
THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO WRITE
THAT DIRECTIVE OR NOT BUT IT
CERTAINLY WAS.
WAS ENOUGH OF A DIRECTION TO US
WE NEEDED TO COMPLY.
OM.
AT RISK OF LOSING THE STATE
CONTRACT IF WE FAILED TO COMPLY.
SO WE DID ARM.
IN BRIGHTWOOD WENT OUT OF
BUSINESS A FEW WEEKS LATER.
WHICH I MEAN THE THE BOTTOM LINE
THE STORY COULD HAVE GONE MUCH
WORSE THAN THAT SO FORTUNATELY
ONE OR THE OTHER ON VETERANS OF
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
BENEFITTED A SCHOOL THAT'S GOING.
TO THAT'S GOING TO BE OF SOME
VALUE DOWN THE ROAD BUT IT'S
THERE'S A LOT OF THOSE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS CURRENTLY.
CLOTHING ON JUST SO I UNDERSTAND
SO YOU TRY TO SUSPEND BRIGHT
WHERE THEY WERE REPORTER THEY
WERE DISAPPROVED THEN YOU ARE
ALL BASICALLY IRRITATED BEEN
DISAPPROVED FOR ABOUT SIX MONTHS
A YEAR OVER IN BY THE A YEAH.
YES OKAY YEAH DO WE HAVE ARE THE
OTHER QUESTIONS.
A ASSEMBLYMEMBER BROKE.
THANKS MADAM CHAIR IS NICE TO BE
BACK HERE ON THIS COMMITTEE
MISTER SECRETARY GOOD TO SAY I
ENJOYED OUR CONVERSATION LAST
WEEK.
THANKS FOR YOUR SERVICE IN THE
ARMY OUR COUNTRY THANKS FOR
CONTINUE SERVICES A SECRETARY
JUST OF QUICKLY FOLLOW UP ON
THAT.
ARE THERE ANY SCHOOLS ON YOUR
RADAR SCREEN RIGHT NOW THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT COULD BE
IN TROUBLE --
I I WOULDN'T I WOULDN'T I'M.
THERE'S THERE'S THERE'S USUALLY
ARE OUR STAFF VERY ACTIVE
THERE'S ALWAYS SCHOOLS BEING
APPROVED OR OR THEY'RE IN SOME
PROCESS OF THE APPROVAL SO.
I'M I'M SORRY NO THAT DOESN'T
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION BUT I I
DON'T HAVE THE SHORE A SHORT
LIST OF FOLKS THAT ARE.
THAT ARE THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
pIT'S BEEN WELL DOCUMENTED HERE
RECENTLY THAT ASHFORD --
ONCE AGAIN.
APPLIED TO CALIFORNIA --
AND WE OPTED --
TO I NOTICE OF INTENT NOT TO ACT
WHICH IS IT'S ONE OF THE OPTIONS
WE HAVE WITHIN THE CODE OF
FEDERAL FEDERATIONS --
WE HAVE HAD A BIT OF YOU KNOW IN
A AND THIS IS ALL PUBLIC
INFORMATION IN.
IN ONE NEWSPAPER ANOTHER BUT THE
V. A SEND US A NOTE.
STATING THAT THEY FELT WE DIDN'T
HAVE THAT OPTION --
DUE TO THE COOPERATIVE AGREEMENT
THAT WE SIGNED SO SILLY
RESPONDED WHICH IS ALSO NOTED IN
THE ARTICLE --
WITH AN ATTACHMENT OF MY LETTER
TO THEM WHICH SHOWED THAT --
IT'S IT'S I WANTED TO IN THE
WEEDS WITH THAT BUT MORE OR LESS
THE LAW SAYS YOU HAVE OPTIONS A.
B. AND C. AND THE V. A SANE
WORLD BASED ON OUR COOPERATIVE
AGREEMENT WE ONLY WANT TO GIVE
YOU OPTIONS A AND B. SO --
IT'S IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT ARE STILL YET TO BE WORKED
OUT BUT ASHFORD AS YOU KNOW IS
ON IT MAY NOW IT'S THEIR
CURRENTLY HAVE A VARIETY OF LOS
IT'S GOING ON NATIONWIDE WITH A
VARIETY OF ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
INCLUDING OUR OWN.
SO BASICALLY THAT THAT NOTICE OF
INTENT NOT TO ACT IS REALLY IT'S
KIND OF THE FAIR THING TO DO --
IT WOULD BE PREMATURE OF US TO
APPROVE ASHFORD'S INFORMATION
ARE ARE DECLINE OR SAY THEY
DON'T MEET THE STANDARDS NOT
KNOWING WHAT.
THAT LAWSUIT IS GONNA TURN OUT
TO BE.
ARM AND IT WOULD KIND OF BE A
DERELICTION OF OUR DUTY TO
APPROVE THEM --
NOT KNOWING HOW THE LAWSUIT
TURNS OUT AS WELL SO THIS PART
OF THE CODE ALLOWS FOR A STATE
UPROOTING SHE TO REFER THIS BACK
TO THE VA.
ON WHICH THEN THE ASHFORD DOES
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
APPROVED OR DENIED DIRECTLY BY
THE VA SO.
I'M NOT SURE THE VA'S THRILLED
ABOUT HAVING A BALL AND FOR OVER
SOME OTHER ISSUES IN ARIZONA.
BUT THE OLD THE REGULATIONS ALSO
STATE VERY CLEARLY THE VA AT
THAT POINT WOULD BE --
REQUIRED TO HAVE THE FTC OR
ANOTHER AGENCY --
LOOKING TO OUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S CONCERNS IN A NOTHER
AG'S CONCERNS AND THEN THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION ON HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH ASH --
FOR BUT FOR US PERSONALLY WE'VE
NEVER EVEN GOT TO THE A
SUBSTANTIVE REVIEW OF ASHER'S
APPLICATION --
JUST BECAUSE WE WE FILLED IT
WOULDN'T BE.
TO BE THE RIGHT THING WENT ONCE
YOU RECEIVED IT AND THIS IS THE
THAT WE DID THIS LAST TIME.
THEIR DATA.
APPLIED IN THE VA HAD NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT.
ON AN INTERESTING ENOUGH THIS
TIME THE ASHFORD PERCENT BACK AT
THE VA'S REQUEST SO THAT WAS
KIND OF ODD KNOWING THAT.
ON THE PUTTING CALIFORNIAN AND
REALLY AWKWARD SITUATION WHEN
THE BALL'S CLEARLY IN THEIR
COURT SO.
WILL YOU KNOW IF YOU KEEP YOU
INFORMED ABOUT THAT AND
CHRISTIAN FOLLOWS A VERY CLOSELY.
IN TOUCH WITH OUR OFFICE SO.
ON I'M SURE I'LL KEEP THE
COMMITTEE UP TO SPEED ON WHAT
HOW THAT'S MOVING ALONG BUT ON
THAT'S THE ONLY THING THAT'S
REALLY GLARING THAT'S IF YOU
WOULD KEEP US UP TO DATE OF
HEARING POTENTIALLY DOWN THE
ROAD -- TEN
ON A POSITIVE NOTE IN MY
DISTRICT WEBSITE ABOUT COLLEGE
TARRANT WONDER TERRENCE NELSON
RUNNERS IS TESTED VETERANS
RESOURCE CENTER DOWN THERE.
LOT OF ANGEL PENDLETON DISCHARGE
START THEIR EDUCATION THEIR
SADDLEBACK SO --
IN APPRECIATE SUPPORT OF THOSE
CONSERVE TURNS IS WONDERFUL HE
WAS HE WAS PART OF OUR PILOT
PROGRAM AT CAMP PENDLETON WITH --
CAL TOP PROGRAM SO HE'S THE ONE
WHO COMES IN AND TEACHRS FOLKS
HOW TO ACCESS THE COMMUNICATIVE
SYSTEM AND AND SO FORTH SO YEAH
HE'S HE'S WONDERFUL GUY RUNS A
GOOD SHOW DOWN THERE.
RIGHT WE ARE RUNNING.
OUT OF TIME BUT I JUST.
OF FOR AND THE SECRETARY.
OF THE V. H. H. P. PROGRAM LOOKS
LIKE IT'S GOING VERY WELL AND
AND I KNOW MY DISTRICT ARE A
COUPLE OF HOMES THAT ARE BEING
BUILT.
BEFORE WE LOOK AT AND AND YOU'VE
JUST SAID IN YOUR STATEMENT THAT
THERE'S A FEW MORE ROUNDS OF
FINANCING BEDS --
BUT ARE ARE YOU GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT WHETHER --
THERE IS ADDITIONAL NEED BE
BEYOND THE CURRENT FUNDING HOW
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO EVALUATE
HOW THAT PROGRAM IS DOING AND
THEN MAYBE FOR JUST FOLLOW THAT
UP WITH YOUR WRAPPED UP --
WELL -- AND
AND YOU CAN KEEP THIS SEMESTER
VHS PS OF FOR HIS WE'VE PUT OUT
IT'S GOING TO BE AT BY THE END
OF THIS YEAR MADE. FORTY THREE
ELEVEN THREE OUT OF THREE ELEVEN
WILL PROBABLY GET TO FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION.
THEIR SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THE KITTY SO WE'VE
PROBABLY BRING TO A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN HALF --
BUT WE WILL KEEP LOOKING
BALANCING THE NEED AGAINST WHAT
WE STILL HAVE TO OFFER INTO THAT
WE KNOW THAT MANY OTHER
COMMUNITIES IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS IN GENERAL ARE
LIKELY TO SCOOP UP VETERANS IN
THAT MIX ALSO BUT WE HAVE OUR
PULSE ON THE ON THE VETERAN
SPECIFIC HOMELESS --
YOU KNOW WE GOT 10% OF THE
NATION'S POPULAR 12% NATION'S
POPULATION 10% OF THE NATION'S
VETERANS. 29% OF THE NATION'S
HOMELESS AND 54% OF THE NATION'S
ON SHELTERED VETERANS MEANING
THOSE VETERANS WHO DO NOT HAVE A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD OF ANY KIND.
SO WE'RE WE'RE EARLY IN EVERY
OTHER WHICH WAY OBLIGATED TO
WORK ON THIS SO WILL CONTINUE
JUST TO STUDY THAT AND IF YOU --
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THERE WILL BE
MORE NEED WHEN WE GET INTO THE
FIFTH AND SIXTH NOW.
FOR MY AND JUST AND JUST ADD
THAT'S KIND IT TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION MORE SPECIFICALLY
THAT'S HOW WE GET TO THAT NUMBER
IS.
THAT NUMBER HE TALKED ABOUT HIS
ON SHELTERED THE THE POINT TIME
COUNT THAT TAKES PLACE AT THE
END OF THIS MONTH BOMB.
BASICALLY GIVES YOU WHAT ON
SHELTERED MEANS IS THAT GOING TO
THING THEY SAY THE SOME THE
HOMELESS FOLKS THEY HAVE IN THIS
AREA THIS IS HOW MANY ON SHELTER
ON SHELTER IS THE NUMBER WHEN
YOU TAKE.
HOMELESS MINUS ALL CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE HOUSING OPTIONS.
HOW WHAT'S THE SHORTFALL THERE --
AND THEN YOU GET A NUMBER SO
CHEN IS AROUND SIX OR SEVEN
THOUSAND FOR THE STATE GENERALLY
FOR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS IT HAS
IT WENT UP A LITTLE LAST YEAR.
BUT SO WE'LL SEE HOW THAT IS ARM.
WE PUT OUT SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
AROUND.
THE NEXT NO FOR IS TO BE
RELEASED IN THE FALL SO THAT
WOULD BE A GRANTING PERIOD
SOMETIME AROUND THIS TIME NEXT
YEAR PROBABLY.
AND WE'RE PUTTING ASIDE EVERY
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AFTER THAT SO
YOU FIGURE SEVENTY FIVE AND
SEVENTY FIVE TO ONE FIFTY WE
HAVE. THREE YEARS OR SO.
LEFT ON MAYBE TWO MORE ROUNDS
AND THEN THE THIRD ROUND WILL
RAFTER RELOOK REALLY HARD IT
WHETHER.
THIS NEEDS TO BE MAYBE BEFORE
THAT BUT LOOK REALLY HARD AT
WORK WHERE THIS NEEDS TO BE AND
THEN THAT'S HOW WE GET TO THAT
NUMBER OF UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THAT GAPS GOING TO BE IS TAKING
ON SHELTER VERSUS HOW MANY.
WE'VE BUILT AND THEN.
I KIND OF DO A LITTLE MATH THERE
AND TRY TO SORT OUT EXACTLY HOW
MANY THAT LEAVES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
DO YOU HAVE SOME RAP RUNNING UP
REMARKS CEREMONIAL BUT YOU KNOW
THIS IS CEREMONY SO --
I AM PROUD TO REPORT YOU ALL
THAT TO A CAL THAT HAS
TRANSFORMED INTO AN ORGANIZATION
THAT IS STRONG HEALTHY.
EFFECTIVE AND FORWARD LOOKING.
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THANK CALAVERAS DEDICATED
LEADERS ALMOST ALL OF WHOM ARE
HERE WITH ME --
TODAY AND OUR STAFF FOR GETTING
US HERE I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
SINCERE GRATITUDE TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND TO THE BROWN ADMINISTRATION
FOR CONSISTENT SUPPORT OF THIS
DEPARTMENT.
WITHOUT THIS STRONG PARTNERSHIP
AND POSITIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WE WOULD BE MUCH
FURTHER AWAY FROM FULFILLING OUR
MISSION.
BUT WE SEE THAT OUR WORK IS NOT
DONE AND WE HAVE HOW THAT SHOULD
BE NOTHING LESS THAN THE MODEL
FOR THE NATION IN SERVING
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THROUGH OUR IN DURING
PARTNERSHIP AND WITH THE
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT OF THE
NEWSOME ADMINISTRATION I'M
CONFIDENT WE WILL ACHIEVE THAT
GOAL SO I THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. FOR YOUR ATTENTION
AND FOR YOUR INVITATION TODAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND YOUR STAFF AND
THANK YOU TO ALL THE MEMBERS FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY.
BUT THAT WORDS ARE